hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Rio fear okay oh gosh I've
totally forgotten let me be better Oh
doors open anyway don't matter all right
I know it's been a while since I got
back into this but I promise I'm
actually gonna kill this douchebag now
and I'm gonna listen to what someone
said and just drop the flashlight
obviously I don't really need it right
now anyway while I'm trying to kill this
guy so here we go it's a [ __ ] dead
okay bring it bring it douche nozzle
where is you ah
hey son of a [ __ ] son of a [ __ ] huh
what what huh yeah that's what I thought
ha ha oh you're on the other side now I
don't know why the reticle doesn't close
all the way feel like it should
did you go where'd you go where'd you go
ready to go hello doc ha there you are
how'd you get on the other side every
don't matter you did all the same BAM Oh
done a half health now I see you I see
you boom come on boom there we go heads
lotion let me go get your ammo that's
not needed just found them blood what's
your gun there it is
got it coming doctor coming for ya Huh
What huh what you see that's scared yeah
why is why is my reticle not closing why
is it not closed when I crouch when I
stop moving
hi does that throw off my aiming is it
only huh nope gotcha
come on
reloading [ __ ] this guy
I made a fool out of me ah see ya are
you out of ammo ha you can reload where
did you get all that ammo I gave you
that gun so I would hope to not murder
oh yeah right the bags ha ha ha almost
got you
let me just reload my health bar just in
case I always like to be oh yeah okay
now my gun out and finish this [ __ ]
off your I didn't even need to use my
syringe I got him
Cybermen the pills by itself won't make
you feel better
sure day we are national moustache I
recommend that you try a new model
treatment cognitive therapy is there why
I'm in this help what's that well it's a
set of exercises way to forget the past
how the bad memories exciting that are
you interested in those
books hey losers why a bunch of good
read books all right I just wanted to
find out because our gym to try outside
the book really screwed up in crazy book
I guess I can try
ah all right then hmm dice my throat's
still not quite 100% after all after I
lost my voice still got a little bit of
cough okay now oh I still have a syringe
left I thought I used them all up
now I can pick up drop this pistol for
the new pistol but I don't know how much
ammo Allah no one holds eight shots -
excuse me sorry about that
revolver rounds I don't even have a
revolt oh this guy had a revolver
afterwards okay yeah I'm just gonna drop
this shotgun I suppose ya know ya wear
my Glock go do my clock just vanish well
I guess I'm not using that gun anymore
hopefully this one is as a powerful as
it claims what the hell give me every oh
hey guys want to miss my flashlight I
can't even hold a flashlight uh alright
I guess I got to go down in the dark
actually now I'll just drop this
morphine on your flashlight no way I can
get out picked around without a
flashlight that's just stupid
there we go okay I'm on my way Marie I'm
making progress
I was kind of thinking that maybe after
that I killed the doctor that be at the
end but it's apparently a whole nother
chapter
just animal those are birds really birds
that seems not right how do I get to the
back door ah the back door that's easy
okay now let me go get my shotgun again
because I don't want to lose that
shotgun the shotgun is powerful like
I'll get out just a little backtracking
will save me a lot of pain I suppose by
these boxes going yeah yeah what where'd
that come from
sorry sorry Glock but I got another
pistol Remington yeah I got plenty of
ammo for this too so is there any way I
can get I can like duct tape combine the
flashlights to them no mine it to the
shotgun no oh I don't like some duct
tape Oh God okay what I think got really
dark why did it suddenly get dark
that was weird oh whatever
backdoor oh my god it's sunshine what oh
that's the telescope okay I was like
what maybe I am close to the end
I mean God's sunshine and niceness
something's gonna go wrong I just know
that that's not my home
don't trust any of this oh that's me
stepping on broken glass that's what I
heard in the bus oh okay or revolve
around I don't have a revolver I don't
trust any of this not even a little bit
do not trust at all this is an illusion
I know it's pretty but come on now I
guess I didn't need the flashlight I
don't like any of this I do not trust a
bit of this nope don't trust this
nice nice reflection nice water that's
really nice water for half light one
don't trust it okay oh no oh oh
somehow this is bad I would think it'd
be hard to row with that shot shoulder
like that but look at him go Simon's Oh
Beast
oh so strong music's getting creepy
does Simon live on the other side of a
lake behind a mental hospital
don't trust any of this this guy's
moving oh no son like going down super
fast seriously the whole skybox is
moving you can tell or maybe that's just
a simulation clouds move and I don't
know maybe I'm freaking out at nothing
but I'm prepared for anything to jump
out at me and startle me any of this
oh I recently updated cry fear and
apparently there's a patch that has
custom stories for cry of fear like
amnesia does and I would love or love
the place for good crying for your
custom joy because man this game it's
built on for scariness it looks more
like a sunset than a sunrise what's that
oh it's raining
oh don't like that I've said it before I
don't like any of this this I know trust
anything that was more broken glass
okay good they're giving me the other
ammo come on
I'm not crazy am i something something's
gonna happen right no no no no nope nope
I knew it come into the light powerful
[Music]
I was ready for all of you ready hey hey
hey yeah huh huh
oh good thing my hands are illuminated
though okay I'm better stop freaking out
and scare me not at all I know what that
up
warm warm ah we got hot dog now wasting
ammo on you [ __ ]
no I mean we will punch it with my fist
their job cool don't know why my bullets
didn't good you under the water walk
womp womp Asst whammy
I don't need bullets to take care of
those guys I see
the idea is come on out womp womp womp
womp womp don't care I punch harder than
you did I got a rejuvenate my jumping
meter I don't know if I'm ever gonna
give my health back after that honey all
right fine you know what I got hang on
again let me reload this gun is really
powerful I think a head shot like it
kills things hold your head still home
and one more come on come on I just said
this gun was dull powerful hey hold any
more well that's deep
oh okay time to swim we love swimming I
want some at a puddle of water
underwater
oh no that's way up for air I got air
shut up Simon you can't hold your breath
no all right hope I hit a save point
soon
hey Jeff huh yeah oh come on get up - go
on lose it help
come on time you can't climb up that
stupid thing shut up prop up that water
and let's go man knocking oh my breath
for at least alright care if he's shot
this I'll get up there get up there are
you kidding me oh that's good you
rejuvenate your health after you lose it
like that but still not cool another one
must be the way out is soonish there we
go
I don't know if there's like a bubble
timer
another one look oh this is way out
whoo yeah oh yeah was there anything
back down there
let me check let me check to see some
goodies nope it's just an iron gate
nevermind let's go okay door is locked
oh there - all right actually I'm just
gonna cut it here I'm not gonna stop
playing um thank you guys so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next part
bye bye